Rhomeyn Johnson, Actor: You have to realize who you are, what you
can do and see for me I know there's
nothing else I can do. So I have no...I
burnt all...I purposely burned all my
bridges leaving Detroit.
Film Courage: Do you think most people go home because
of the rejection or they have very
strong pulls from friends and family and
it's comfort, it's safety and I'll miss them
and it's not always that way here
especially if you're working a little
survival job in the gig industry that's
not it's not that it's all of that it's
not just the fact that you can't do your
your acting or whatever it's all of
those factors it's all of that I mean
that's why that's why I say it's this is
this is a calling to me this is a
calling to be this see when you when
it's a calling there's nothing that can
take you away from it I mean you know
you get sick of whatever like my mother
fell and hurt herself
now if I had to go and I went home for a
couple of weeks to tend to my mother if
I had to go home to take care of my
mother I would do that because he family
comes first you know if I had to say
okay I'm gonna have to go home for a
while I will do that
see so it's not like no no no if this is
this an emergency situation that always
to me takes precedence over this because
you can't I couldn't be happy or really
concentrate knowing that my mama or
somebody needs me and they helpless I
couldn't you know you can't you can't
function so I mean I would do that but
if it's about the fact that you know the
pool like I dated a girl that was here
from Chicago and we went to see a movie
and in at the Sherman Oaks Galleria and
when we left a movie she got a call from
her from her mother
anyway I have enough cook out in the
backyard or something so this is like we
went to see it like a early matinee you
know around 12 or something like that so
after the movie was always around 2
o'clock or whatever Mack in Chicago was
4 o'clock and it was on I think of
Saturday or something and her mother
calls oh because oh we got barbecue we
got potato salad we got all this
stuff Oh everybody asking about you and
we were walking going to you know you we
walk into the car you know you've been
in the gallery right so we were walking
to the car on the ground and then she
stopped dead in her tracks and start
talking and all of a sudden she said
okay I'll call you back mom I'll call
you back
she hung up on the phone and stopped
broke down start crying so naturally
people who walking pass it what did you
do people looking at me like did you hit
her
did you I'm like I'm just standing here
she started crying and said I want to go
home and we got in the car and she cried
and cried we didn't even we didn't even
take off we just sat in the car and she
said what should I do I said you should
go home she said really I said go home I
say you
you you need to go home because you
feeling that she said but I don't I said
don't worry about me or your agents and
all these people you got to do what's
best for you if it means being in this
business be in this business if it means
going Hong Kong she went home made her
old sweetheart had a kid beautiful
little girl
and he ran off and left it was doing you
know and we talk all the time you know
what she said oh yeah you know I said
well now is he taking care of his
responsibilities is he giving you they
got divorced I say are you getting your
alimony in it
oh yeah oh you don't
okay but but it's like you have to you
have to realize who you are what you can
do and and see me I know there's nothing
else I can do so I have no I burned all
I purposely burned all my bridges
leaving Detroit because the last real
job I had in Detroit you know while I
was still studying my stuff I quit on
them and actually they had to terminate
me because I moved I went to Chicago and
wouldn't come back I took a leave of
absence
certified social worker for the state of
Michigan I didn't go back so my boss had
to I had to come back and I went to the
job and she's crying while she's writing
the termination papers all the people in
this Inn and I'm hugging them and it's
gonna be all right I don't want to get
fired that's okay they said I was
hugging and consoling them and they had
to fire me and then he won't I said no
no no they said you could have taken a
long-term leave I said no I said I'd
needed to burn this bridge I can't go
back over this bridge because alligators
in that moat down there and they if I
try to cut through the water they gonna
chew me up I can't go over this bridge I
burnt that bridge down see I had to burn
them down because I said this is what I
have to do this is what I have to do and
people in this industry as you know we
driven we driven now I don't I don't put
everything into this I mean like I said
when I get home I mean I put everything
into this when I'm working auditioning
or whatever and all that when I get home
I said okay I'm putting that aside I've
learned that over the years okay I gotta
put that to the side so I watched
football basketball oh I do do all kind
of other stuff other than the business
you know I don't get high so I can't do
like a lot of my friends that smoke weed
oh yeah I don't do that anymore so I
have to just do other stuff but you have
to get away from it sometimes you know
and you have to just do that but like
like like like we was saying there's
always gonna be a pool of some type it's
always gonna be a pool and I mean even
when I got into business I had so much I
have so many people calling me crazy
when I first got in it because they
didn't understand what I was doing
because this is all the way he's a flake
anyway
you know he's you know I had a girl that
you know I knew I was at a party and she
found out I was doing aspiring for this
early and she had gone out and went to
New York with the Alvin Ailey Dance
Company and whatnot and she didn't make
it
so I was at a party and I'm sitting at a
table with her and her boyfriend you
know and she says you gonna try to do
what she said you'll never make it
because I couldn't make it so if I
couldn't make it I know you can't and I
was like sitting there like okay and I
had people doing me like that then I
would have I would meet women you know
you know I would try to date him or
whatever and they'd be say Oh what do
you do for a living I said well I'm an
actor they said oh you are what if I
seen you in or have you whatever you
done you know and if I'm if I'm saying
well I really haven't done much then now
you know it's like he's a loser they
looked at me and and I had that that L
on my forehead you know for them which
is the loser you know and I actually had
women whispering he's a bum he's a loser
I mean I had all kind of stuff I'm like
okay all right and and as the years went
on and I start doing stuff I would get
few and front questions like that now I
don't get that anymore and if I ever get
any of those kind of questions somebody
said well whatever you done what can I
see you in I can give him lists I said
oh I was a recurring character on Parks
and Rec I was a police chief
I got a commercial right now running for
Liberty Mutual that's running every two
seconds I can't go anywhere without
people not recognizing me we just bleed
me the airport everybody need a mutual
get them like crazy okay so what I say
and I get like I say very few questions
like that because it's been 30 years I
mean 30 years and I you know I used to
have people say well why don't you use
your good
I mean with your college and I'll say
well I've been I went to school for like
what 17 years you started what sighs I
guess I said I went all until I was like
21 22 you know how I was a year behind
because I played sports and had to drop
classes because I was always traveling
you know so I was I was like a I was
like a five year college graduated not a
four year you know so that's my scarlet
letter you know he came out inside
instead of four oh but you know it's
like 17 years of school I said okay I
went through that life for 17 years I've
been doing this 30 so are you they said
oh I said yeah it's like I'm out of that
stuff but no I you know it's like now
now I don't have that problem with women
problem I got now is I got women trying
to take my money okay that's a whole no
that's another subject altogether you
know I mean try to get this money
because they know I got some money see
so now somebody calling me here oh okay
and just keep killing who does here I
knew with her
you